get back you move this time I have a
wheel of punishment with a bunch of
things I absolutely don't want to do if
I laugh I gotta roll it the wheel
alright here we go five inch platforms
to the gym to get my husband's reaction
hell yeah where can I get those
the water bottle yes please
[Laughter]
oh God damn this is the same reaction
everyone has when they see my shoes you
know what those are given though
you like it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no I'm actually scared of laughing I
definitely don't want to do this
punishment let me ask you my friend
that's last question what happened to
you here
where did I bash my head here but I just
got sandwich on my head you have
something here red on on the right on
the right here how do you not see that
it's probably his father's sandwich
you know what it was Christ I didn't
even look there so they've sent me this
this wonderful ring flash which I've set
up with an iPad in the middle of it and
I went like this like that and it just
fell on my head just before
[Laughter]
well it's been the whole interview like
that so
I love it because this is this is 17
years playing Bond can you see him
well you showed
thank you no literally I could have just
was setting this out anyway
[Laughter]
well I'm very happy that it's not
something that happened to you I like
how we saved it for the last that's
funny fine I spin the wheel I laugh on
purpose okay
[Music]
this was definitely the worst punishment
just to make it tolerable
a whole glass of water
I sure hope I don't laugh again
stop it's your time to Spin the Wheel of
Fortune G fuel is giving away a thousand
dollars and a year supply of PewDiePie G
fuel the greatest drink known to man
water
post whatever you want online PewDiePie
G fuel related Twitter Instagram
wherever tag G fuel energy hashtag G
field PewDiePie and you're in it could
be funny it could be impressive it could
be epic there will be five winners based
on creativity and originality I will
react to the winners in a follow-up
video a thousand dollars an infinite G
fuel for a year is at stake now go make
me mad thank you g Phil for sponsoring
this video enter code PewDiePie as
always when you stock up
let's keep going my uncle doesn't
believe I have a construction job
I've got low construction on site here
why are you looking why are you just
saying you're gonna kick them people out
y'all what you talking about nobody live
here a family of five living them boots
[Applause]
trailer parks but you got two mobile
homes with chimneys
[Applause]
put down the lines they put the white
paint on your foot and you just stick it
out make the lines
all right then I gotta spin the wheel
God damn it all right here we go
come on
no
no
[Applause]
this is the word this is actually the
worst one
all right now wait now I'm actually just
mad
holy holy [ __ ]
[Music]
hey guys
[Laughter]
damn it I'm sucking this
all right
come on
no no
ah
[Applause]
Jesus Christ God damn it God damn it all
right no more no way 57 year old man who
was caught speeding at almost 200
kilometers per hour a couple of months
ago refused to pay his speeding fine
claiming that everything he does is fast
according to the man he eats off he
sleeps fast he drives fast he reads fast
and even walks fast when he had to
appear on court today he explained the
same thing to a Western Cape George who
replied let's see how fast you can do a
six months in prison
I left it the wrong fit
my apartment
all right all right no more no more
donate no more donate
I gotta delete a video at least I didn't
get donate okay fine fine I'll delete
video I have 109 Amnesia videos
one of them is going to go bye-bye
slender meets amnesia
is deleted forever
so long
I mean
so long all right no more no more left
no more what's up guys so I thought I
would give you all my morning routine
my followers have been asking for money
I can't believe I almost laugh at this
it's a funny idea every morning wake up
at 5am
and I get the morning pump get the
morning time
it's contagious laughter come on
all right
sorry what does line one line mean
doesn't have to be two lines right yeah
right there on the thing I forgot it I'm
sorry my bad my bad
it's on the team
he's looking at me
are up
amazing
[Laughter]
you said that from a jokes though
did you get it from a jokes though no
wait wait did you what you got a blue
marker you got a blue marker you got a
blue marker that's it Jesus fix it
really really
is this real yes
he was here no the hell yeah God damn
the plus sign we about to add another
Edition
[Music]
he wasn't ready
it's 38 goddamn uh that's what he meant
with the A-Team
you is hilarious
oh no
oh no
don't donate don't
I deserve this
It's gotta be like a I gotta tank it
if I move my head towards my hand
there's something mentally stopping me
from doing this
foreign
I thought for sure there will be some
mental barrier to stop me but now
right I can do that apparently
[Music]
you shaved it
used it she saved myself you [ __ ]
weirdo
did you think I was gonna notice no
did you why'd you say that sorry
that's so good what
are you coming
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
she seems to me
it's uh oh God all right
come on glass of water
buy some water
fine
I have 91 videos of Happy Wheels that
will now be 90. episode 51
so now
it's really working hard on thumbnails
back in the day huh
am I red
I made that guy's morning
[Music]
I like that I like that video but I will
not lie Ben Stiller's impression we
almost finished each other's sentences
kinda all right I mean I don't think
we've ever finished each other sentences
[Laughter]
I'm weird
fine
Roll video I mean wheel
oh my God I can't but I already have to
pee I drank one
jeez Gamers stay hydrated
disgusting
no G feel what's the point is that a
nice chair yeah
the better than the one you have at home
yeah you have a chair for myself yeah no
way remember Mom and Dad bought it for
you I have a bug
do you know who I am yeah
[Music]
now
that you have two sisters
[Music]
well they're at work
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God
what a crazy coincidence
Batman
all right last one
come on
oh my God are you
I have done way too many you laugh you
lose it's not 10 million oh it's not
monetized delete it delete it get out of
my sight rest in peace fellow you laugh
you lose I'm gonna go I'm backwards
videos now this is not very productive
hey bro
happy Halloween
thank you yeah you're welcome
hey bro
happy Halloween on the other side
here we go
you're welcome dude
what a homie oh yeah go ahead
yeah
you can have another one if you want
yeah
[Music]
laughs
you're welcome guys
[Music]
all right come on
I think the slot was definitely the
worst
I don't want that again
[Applause]
ah I held back I held back I held back
foreign
all right we lost some brain cells today
we lost some videos but we had a good
time if you enjoyed video subscribe for
more check out G fuel leave a comment of
more appropriate punishments for next
one and I see you then bye bye